From telescopes to the large head on collider
each new scientific tool will invent revise the questions
that we as a scientists
and curious minds can reasonably ask
high performance computing or hbc
joined that elite list in the sixties today
quantum computers are knocking at the same door.
Welcome my name is is conducive to coffee
and i'm software engineer here at ibm quantum
in this course we aim to teach students
and professionals ally how quantum computing will soon
work together with hbc infrastructures
to deliver computat
you will learn how quantum
and classical computers communicate and exchange data
how to write programs that exploit both types of hardware
and how this integration open sub applications we can solve today
you'll build practical experience with real quantum hardware
and classical high performance computing clusters
running quantum jobs alongside traditional hbc workloads
and keep use interpret results with confidence
and identify places where quantum acceleration
could genuinely help calculations
and where it doesn't above all you will understand
where the future of computers headed
and the old map that will take us there we think
this course is both important
and timely and we believe
combining this technologies will be essential
to achieving computational advantage
this could have wide ranging impacts across industries
like chemistry possibly enabling
faster drug design and materials research
in finance
for smarter risk models
and fraud detection in artificial intelligence in machine learning
for model optimisation in this course
will dive deep into computer resources
programming models and quantum all greater
so welcome and get crazy
a lot to discuss